40% c'est la part des idées de la
convention climat qui figureront dans la
prochaine loi énergie climat
déclarations de barbara pompili ministre
de la transition écologique au micro de
nos confrères d'europe 1 ce lundi matin
alors que le gouvernement présente une
version définitive du projet de jours
grande majorité ces propositions sera
dans le projet de loi sur le climat
on y travaille d'arrache-pied vous savez
c'est c'est une loi qui va changer de
modèle français qui va mettre l'écologie
dans le modèle français est ce qu'on
veut c'est surtout que ce soit pas juste
une loi d'incantation 80 articles de
l'ensemble des mois de travail qui se
voulait être une expérience démocratique
inédite selon l'elysée mais qui ont
envie de renvoyer le gouvernement dans
ses travers et créer des tensions entre
le chef de l'état et plusieurs membres
de la convention citoyenne pour le
climat cyril dion cinéaste est membre de
ladite convention n'a pas hésité à s'en
prendre directement aux locataires de
l'elysée pour dénoncer les méthodes du
gouvernement et les promesses non tenues
des manuels macron il n'en fallait pas
moins pour faire sortir le président de
ses gonds et s'en prendre aux militants
écologistes
je suis très en colère contre des
activistes qui m'ont aidé au début et
qui maintenant me disent qu'il faudrait
tout prendre je les respecte mais je ne
vais pas dire ce qu'ils proposent c'est
la bible ou le coran entre le cinéaste
et le président le divorce semble
prononcé au delà de la perplexité que
m'évoque cette morgue à mon endroit dans
la bouche du président de la république
il me semble que c'est vous qui ne
respectaient pas la parole que vous avez
donnée tenir sa parole pour un président
de la république c'est le socle de notre
démocratie
manque de communication manque de
transparence ou de considérations mises
devant le fait accompli ou encore
silence radio sur certains points le
gouvernement semble rester fidèle à ses
méthodes là où justement l'objectif
était le rapprochement des français à
travers ce que vous voulez être je cite
une expérience démocratique inédite
on devait rencontrer les parlementaires
selon un processus de co construction
avec des rendez vous d'explication sur
les mesures et l'a finalement les
citoyens et les parlementaires vont se
voir présenter les esquisses du projet
de loi du gouvernement
on est mis devant le fait accompli
n'était pas sur ça qu'on s'était mis
d'accord au départ l'auteur de mai
goasguen avait promis d'être le super
défenseur de la planète le président
climat mais dans les faits cela a du mal
à se concrétiser dès le départ de cette
convention n'est de la crise des gilet
jaune
des tensions étaient palpables notamment
lorsque le sujet de la 5g a été mis sur
la table alors que plusieurs membres de
la convention avait demandé un moratoire
gouvernement à ce sujet ils ont eu le
droit à une référence aux amish de la
part du président en personne
autre point de cette fiction baisse de
la tva compliqué pour le moment baisse
des billets de train pour inciter les
français à moins utiliser la voiture
compliqué pour le moment interdire la
publicité pour les véhicules polluants
compliqué pour le moment et la liste des
requêtes insatisfaite est encore longue
une notion de sans filtre qui ne semble
pas avoir la même saveur du côté de
l'elysée face au manque de transparence
du gouvernement scierie dion a lancé une
pétition pour sauver la convention
citoyenne qui compte déjà pas moins de
340 mille signatures objectif obtenir
une loi climat la plus fidèle possible
aux aspirations de nombreux français
celle qui est née de la mobilisation des
gilet jaune comme un rappel à l'ordre
aux plus hautes sphères de l'état à
l'heure où la maison continue de brûler
18 ans après le discours de jacques
chirac au sommet de la terre de
johannesburg